it's impossible to tell exactly how many
people are arriving here but it
definitely feels busier at the border
today
can i help you there is no let up in the
stream of women and children still
fleeing ukraine welcome welcome
welcome no problem catalin ragazan is
the first face many of them see the
christian minister is here from first
thing in the morning until the border
closes in the evening
hello
he meets them finds out what they want
to do and then arranges for them to go
somewhere warm and comfortable a process
he's done hundreds of times over the
past week
for me every day is busy from the
morning into evening we trying to do
best as we can possible first step is to
receive people to ask what they want so
we help them to go to
where they want by the train by the fly
or maybe they need to rest one day two
days or three days no problem for
example yesterday we had we
had a mother and grandmother
traveling
24 hours by the car so she optioned to
rest one day two days okay don't worry
we want to help you it's become a mini
village here now rows of tents have been
set up and volunteers hand out hot food
and drinks sugary snacks toys for the
children and donated clothes to anyone
who needs them but the united nations
has told us that if the war goes on much
longer then they can't be certain how
europe will continue to cope with this
influx
it is indeed one of the biggest refugee
crisis for for for many decades um
remember public rohingya five years ago
fleeing myanmar
these were 800 000 people but over 12 or
14 weeks now
we had the same figure here after just
five days
of course fleeing ukraine is just the
first step on the journey for most of
the refugees some arrive with a plan
they might have relatives to meet
elsewhere on the continent
but most don't
and so they leave the border behind them
not sure where they're going or when
they'll be back
aleister bunker's sky news on the
ukrainian romanian border